you
hi everyone is Gerry I'm on Ches calm
and I just got paired up playing a 3-2
game let's try a Sicilian play the con
see if white goes for an immediate d4
you do okay
see it's first secure b5 for Queen c7
and immediate knight c6 not so good
because it takes in an e5 I don't get I
get a nice advance in I don't get my
pawn up to d5 so let's say yeah let's
start with Knight to f6 I'm not sure if
there's a too big a difference he
belongs here maybe there's a bit more
flexibility with my queen night mm-hmm
let's bring it here
challenge that Knight now I'm it takes
I'm thinking about just taking with my
deep on I don't think that should be a
problem yeah let's do this so my ideal
play e5 I'm expecting f4 and I think I
could do this pretty much have to I
don't want to allow e4 or excuse me e5
by white because then they have that e4
square hmm to insert this check first
yeah I think I like that let's do this
and then I want to secure my knight
don't want to him harassed with Bishop
g5 um let's see she's probably castle or
b5 mm-hmm b5 is that really let's let's
castle first expecting Bishop here
that's probably why Queen e2 is played
these squares are a little bit sensitive
so moves like Knight a4 might be on the
cards trying to work into these dark
squares it might be a move
let's see they're finally thinking a
little bit night a for Bishop back
Bishop III might be an idea although
maybe on night 84 I could play Bishop to
d4 think about moving forward okay so
they're really trying to kill me here
hmm I probably need to vacate this
square prepare to run with my king
expecting rook to g3 so I'm gonna be
under some pressure here maybe it was a
bit much to commit my king hmm
this is tricky they have three attackers
I only have my knight here as a defender
I'm not sure what to do here actually
they're setting up some sacrifices on h6
let's do this
I'm preparing to run King to this square
let's get some space
had to get my Bishop on this dog and all
it takes a lot of work to do that though
and when my bishop lacy 5c4 might be an
idea I'm even thinking about King here
and then Bishop to f8 mmm looks pretty
crazy I'm gonna do it though Bishop to
f8 just for some defense of g8 I'm
really banking that my e5 pond holds up
and it's half open position I guess we
could say I know how open it is this
could be a little bit awkward the rook
here you know flight squares aren't so
easy to get in they might do g4 g5
certainly I'm not really afraid of that
move let's start with the bishop here
secure d5 I'd certainly like that
capture opens up my bishop
if rook to g3 I'm planning Bishop to f8
and maybe a kick of the night although
it gives up this square and we'll see I
think I have to do something like b4 I
don't know if I doubling is a good idea
I don't know if pivoting on d4 is a good
option rook g3 Bishop to FA I'm not sure
what other candidate moves g4g for
Brooke g3 maybe g4 and then R up to g3 I
would even on time all right let's do
this that was my idea all along so this
is a very good defensive piece knight on
f6 my king is as if he as if he didn't
even castle okay let's see hmm they
might be setting up Queen f2
prepare to double I'm going to do this
runs into the bishop here stuff but I'd
welcome a dark square bishop exchange
like to have my King on this square to
defend g7 mm-hmm
this is tricky okay so they're setting
up Bishop to b6 stuff let's go here
maybe B 4 B 4 and then C 5 you know I
got to be very careful my queen is uh
that's a well placed here maybe a rook
back and then c5 I gotta get the
pressure off of this though hmm this was
a welcome sight if they are gonna
capture I think that's a mistake no
let's take like this I think that was
helpful to me opens up my bishop opens
up my rope we're gonna see dark square
bishop Soph the board I think I could
forced that now if the bishop goes back
to e3 Queen c7 Bishop here although no
there's still pressure on g7 but I don't
know that there's ensuing pressure on g7
it's a bunch of fireworks going off in
the background I know if you hear that
sorry about that I could think about b4
and then taking here huh this is and I'm
not sure what to do move oh I'm actually
running into sacrifices here two pieces
and two pieces given up for a rook and
two pawns yeah they're going for that
but then I get this pawn
we're actually clean takes here let's
try this take with my night
I've pressure on g2 and c2 Bishop is
also pinned let's go to here for
starters I have coordination my rooks on
my orc is actually unprotected now
there's more coordination let's go here
um get my rook over here
this is picking up stuff isn't it hmm
let's see I'm hitting the rook and the
bishop who is pinned he's still pinned
um I'm winning material now okay let's
back up let's go here I guess ten
seconds
let's back up these bishops are monsters
but let's go here maybe pick up this
pawn stop that pawn in his tracks you
should probably get out of this pin soon
um let's go here covering a lot of
squares hitting the rook okay this
should be collapsing now g2 so now I
have a d1 probably missed a bunch of
mates okay I think I have it now finally
Queen takes rook whoo that was very very
difficult and a little bit distracting
with the fireworks in the background but
yeah I don't know if it's gonna be
audible in the video but yeah we're
gonna have a look at this as usual with
stockfish so we'll see what has to say
just give me a second I'll pull that up
okay my initial impression of this game
is that my opponent had some wind
somewhere
without looking at the computer just yet
I think it was just held together by a
thread and my opponent could have broken
it down somehow again before even
looking at it with the computer I think
this idea of G for and only then rook to
g3 would have been better of course see
what the computer suggestion is but I
mean when I when you Castle movie rook
and then play King f8 King EA and it
looks like you didn't even move the King
just somebody passing by watching the
game for a second there's something
clearly off with that and I think the
transition a change in the evaluation
occurred most likely when black excuse
me when white captured on b5 something
was given up with that when I'm able to
have my LightSquared Bishop activated
and also the C file so I think still
keeping the tension if white did that
I'm not sure what I would have done so
let me get stockfish rolling here so
let's get some moves in here also this
will be an interesting point how does
the computer want to take it goes with D
take C okay yeah still pending up the
diagonal for the bishop and I do have to
play e5 this is very important otherwise
I'm getting kicked around 85 and
otherwise yeah if I don't play e5 myself
white plays e5 grabs from space kicks my
knight has to find a new home and the
knight and the bishop but most likely
the knight will occupy the e4 square so
I certainly have to the short story here
is this pawn duo needs to be confronted
as soon as possible so he 5 it is and
the other move I didn't have time to
really my opponent played f5 very
quickly but my idea was Knight g4 and
this is already tipping in blacks favor
notice he will be getting the pawn back
for one and there's already threats of
Bishop to c5 this is maybe a little bit
deceptive because a bit deceptive of an
assessment because White has so much
mint development in but this night
strangely enough is a bit misplaced to
do to the pawn on c6 and the Bishop on
d3 it's not so clear what exactly it's
doing beyond babysitting the D in the e4
pawn so this this is the short story
here if light is to capture on e5 Knight
here and then scoop up the pawn here if
let's say Bishop to f4 well it's already
pawn advantage he's pointing out Queen
b6 King h1 night up to yeah going in for
the exchange something other than that
Queen here it doesn't you don't even
have to take I guess on this square
develop first this pawn is going nowhere
if Bishop f4 now this is starting to
look like fishing pull stuff that I'll
do quite a bit in bullet h5 interesting
move notice on h3 that you don't even
have to react to this this Knight is
actually immune from capture this is a
nice little thing to be aware of if you
can maintain this Bishop maintain
control over this dark diagonal coupled
with the knight on g4 and anchored with
the pond and having the rook there's a
lot of a lot of things needed but this
is quite bothersome to the white side
the knight the bishop are placing a
pretty good restriction on the white
pieces have to constantly be aware of
knight forks on f2 so interesting to
know on takes like g4 would be the
follow up Bishop c5 Queen b6 ideas or
just scooping up the e5 pawn and this is
then an isolated
on a wonderful home on e5 okay didn't
have that f5 it is has it as an even
evaluation Bishop c5 there are some
other shifts doesn't have an issue with
Castle but maybe I should have been a
bit more flexible here my concern with
playing b5 first was that on a4 what do
I do with my rook I wanted to be in a
position to me a4 with a bishop move and
then my Brooks would be defended that's
actually I probably shouldn't have
viewed it like that because on 8th if I
did play b5 right here instead of castle
on a for Bishop b7 is sufficient enough
if takes yeah you just take with the C
pawn as I did in the game yeah I even
even have to defend the rook like that i
oh no I'm sorry you do have to because
of the sacrifices on b5 but for some
reason I was wanting to have you know
before white is in a position to strike
and welcome pawn exchanges and open up
the position I wanted to have castling
in doesn't have an issue with that but I
sure felt like there was a ton of
pressure it says that it's fine for
black it's not the top suggestion but
yeah I wanted to be able to run with my
king I started to smell over these
sacrifices you know they're right around
the corner worksheet 3 Bishop takes h6
oh yeah
doesn't have any issue oh that is an
issue I'm giving it some time to think
okay it's not finding any knockout or
anything okay it does like this g4 idea
did point this out yeah maybe they could
have also saved a move on now on g4 now
it's unprotected although it's not even
thinking about capturing because of
just a free attack along the G file now
well not a free attack but a wonderful
attack for just a pawn investment okay
so look there first and it does like
this idea of g4 I don't know what I
would have done on g4 g4 is in fact the
suggestion b5 in on g5 chop-chop this is
scary
Brooke h6 stuff but you know the tricky
right I mean it is just a check King
here and this is a fantastic piece
important to recognize how how good this
Knight is well I mean currently he's
pinned but you know he couldn't if he's
if he's unpinned there's ideas of rook
to our Knight to g4 he could be a quick
attacker okay they didn't come for the
g4 idea was there any tactic missed here
should be seven it still has it as even
no issue with the little King King walk
here but again I wanted to have that f8
square available for my dark square
Bishop still has it as even King Fe
wasn't my idea
Bishop back okay half pawn advantage b3
yachts it's a lot of slow stuff here
b3 I guess small improving stuff I'm not
sure what the idea is behind b3 maybe to
free up the night so you can move and
try and reposition I'm not sure bit of a
mysterious move b3 yeah I'm not quite
sure and another thing is if I'm very
quick to play d4 you could be sure that
this night is going to post on d2 and
then get into that c4 squared the
weakened square as a result of b4 so
that's why I wanted to hold my ground
there not yet
push this pawn in fact I never did and I
again I don't know what I would have
done if light did not capture on b5
that's where I think we'll see a shift
rook c8 as it as as what after this yeah
that's where there is the shift after
the capture there so what should have
white done King g1 these are tough moves
like I guess it's tough for a y to try
and improve as well but this was only a
help to me this capture they take
and before okay I'm just trying to
improve and yeah I mean we're both
living off of the increment at this
point but they're trying to sacrifice it
should never really be enough the two
minor pieces will almost always be
better but I guess trying to mix it up a
little bit
Queen takes c2 is suggestion but this is
good as well and the other tactics
missed in these uh this ending here like
their Bishop c5 you know okay so it's
just winning this nothing was missed I
guess at the end I was trying to keep it
as clean as possible but I didn't really
have time to even think about how to
keep how to convert it in a clean way
and yeah I guess nothing was
nothing was missed there it's already
reading as I'm mating seven clean there
may inform eight and five where is the
mate I missing queen f4 wants to play
first okay I gave a check still mating
in all cases rook d3 and that's the ball
game here it's important that white
doesn't have any checks here that was
like my last quick glance playing a move
like this is the Queen able to enter
somehow on this diagonal or this rank
but nothing was there Ivana resigned at
this point a tough tough game yeah just
again going going back here what could I
have done different because it's it was
difficult I mean for both of us to
improve but it's very it's very scary I
mean this g4 idea g4 b5 here takes takes
what would be I mean what would do I do
here rook to d1 let's just play out a
couple more moves King e7 ok well now it
starts to become a bit more clear there
is a something has changed with that
pawn captured the H file and the G file
the H files half open so I could think
about occupying it with rook to h8 and
then going from there and maybe all of a
sudden it's the white king who's a bit
more vulnerable ok
well anyhow just to give you a little
bit of an idea as to how the black side
couldn't couldn't improve and again this
idea that white may very well have with
the g4 and g5 advanced ok
as usual feel free to leave any comments
in the comment section below to this
video and as always I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care